What I want you to attempt to
do is given an arbitrary list--
I made a particular example
of an arbitrary list right
here-- write a function that
sorts that arbitrary list.
So maybe you call
your function My Sort,
you can call it whatever.
What I want is after I call
My Sort on a list, the list
itself gets resorted.
So I don't want My Sort to
return a copy of the list.
I want, after I call My Sort
on a, if I then refer to a,
if let's say I do print a,
then that will literally
return a sorted version of a.
Or I should say it will return
a, but now a itself is sorted,
or the list that a is
referring to is now sorted.
So it would now
look like this. a
would now look like
1, 2, 3, 5, 7, 8.
And you might say, wait
Sal, that's very easy,
there is already a sort
function in Python.
You literally can
call a dot sort,
and that will sort a
in place just the way
I've asked you to do.
And when I say in
place, I'm saying
it's actually going to
work on the actual list.
It's not going to create a copy
of the list that is sorted.
It's actually going to work
in place on that actual list.
And a sort does this, but I
don't want you to use that.
So let's cross this off.
The whole point of
this is to learn just
to kind of try our best to
write our own sorting function.
What you're going to
see, and hopefully
appreciate as we go deeper
and deeper into this, is it
there's many, many, many,
many ways to sort things.
And sorting is really a good
way to think about how good
a function, and we'll start
talking about algorithms,
how good a process is,
or how fast a process is,
or how efficient a process
is, at doing something.
So I'll leave you there.
Try to sort this.
In the next video, I'll try
to outline an algorithm, which
is really just a process
for doing something.
I'll outline an
algorithm that's kind
of an intuitive
way to sort things.
It's not the most efficient
And then after that,
I'll try my best try
at actually writing that
algorithm in a Python program.